David I'm signing you to the Home  Secretary very good moment  to move up mom this is Pierce to meet  you mum  I'm late for a meeting she's got an  agenda to heighten fear and to seize  power that doesn't require apologizing  for the past did you mean what you said  I don't need you to protect me  rest assured love I'll do mr. quiet stay  done it's okay it's okay  these plots do not always arise from  outside some fester within  I've been a copper I've been a soldier  for politicians cowards and Liars  what is she up to you need to find out  how do you reckon she'd feel if she got  a toast  you cannot keep pretending you're one  can I heat this  dangerous politician someone's gonna  stop by there's been an Inside Man all  along  looks like the Home Secretary couldn't  be in safer hands  [Music]  you  you